okay let's get started
my name is peter duncan and i'm the
director of product management here at
codex
and welcome to our webinar harnessing
the power of synthetic biology to combat
covet 19.
today i'm really excited to present
three amazing speakers that will all
discuss the highly relevant topic
of global pandemics including covet 19
which we are all currently experiencing
together
dr dan gibson will lead off and discuss
how synthetic biology has been used in
the past for fighting pandemics and how
it can also be utilized today
next katie lyons will talk about how dna
printing can accelerate vaccine research
and development for current and future
pandemics
and then finally dr krishna cannon will
present how we synthesize the world's
first cyrus cup
2 complete full-length genome de novo
and discuss real-world applications of
this work
at the end of the webinar we will have a
q a session where we will do our best to
answer what i'm sure will be many
questions
it is my pleasure to introduce our chief
technology officer dr dan gibson
dan is one of the most influential
thought leaders in the field of
synthetic biology and here are a few
highlights
just recently dan and his team here at
codex have created the world's first
synthetic stars cup 2 full-length genome
which we'll discuss shortly in 2016 he
led a team that developed the first
synthesized minimal cell
in 2010 he constructed the first
synthetic cell
and in 2009 he published what is now the
most widely used method for cloning
the gibson assembly method which has
over four thousand citations
and is a foundational technology for
enabling the world's only dna printer
finally in 2008 dan coe led the team
that constructed the first synthetic
bacterial genome
without further delay i am pleased to
pass the controls over to dan
well thank you peter hello everyone over
the past
15 years my teams have been developing
widely applicable
methods for whole genome design
synthesis and assembly
at codex we are focused on providing
researchers with those tools to rapidly
design and synthesize
high quality dna to accelerate advances
across several fields
including personalized medicine drug
discovery
and vaccine development
in 2010 all of the technologies that
we've developed over the past
20 years for reading and writing dna
converged when we announced the creation
of the first synthetic cell
ever since the sequencing of the first
bacterial genome in 1995
thousands more complete bacterial
genomes have been sequenced and stored
in computer databases the creation of
the first synthetic cell was a proof of
concept
that we could reverse this process pull
a dna sequence out of the computer
and then convert that information into a
free living
self-replicating cell with all the
expected characteristics of the species
that we constructed
this was a project that could not be
accomplished with traditional cloning
methods
and really forced the development of new
and advanced molecular
biology tool sets it also paved the way
for the
generation of synthetic bacteria and
viruses including cyrus cov2
enabling a design-build test cycle at
the whole genome level
our massive efforts to create synthetic
bacteria have made us world experts at
writing dna
throughout these projects we continue to
find ways to write dna faster
more accurately and more reliably and
because of the robustness of these
technologies we found that we could
readily automate the process to move the
workflows
out of the scientists hands and onto a
machine
in 2013 we built the bioxp and it has
become absolutely essential for writing
dna across a variety of applications my
team
and researchers around the world are
working on
we immediately realized the bio xp's
potential to address global pandemics
and started working with a vaccine
manufacturer in the us government to
bring this to fruition
it was shortly after we built the bioxp
that we received an email from an
international health organization
alerting us that two men died in china
shortly after contracting the h7n9 bird
flu
there were fears of a global pandemic as
the virus started rapidly moving across
china
a team of chinese scientists isolated
the virus sequenced the dna and then
posted the dna sequence on the internet
at the request of the us government we
downloaded the dna sequence of the virus
and synthesized the dna
in less than 12 hours on the bioxg and
with our partner we quickly started
turning that dna into a flu vaccine
meanwhile the cdc using technology
dating back to the 1940s was still
waiting for the virus to be delivered
from china so they could begin their
chicken egg based process for making the
vaccine
for the first time we had a flu vaccine
produced ahead of time for a new and
potentially dangerous strain
and the us government ordered a
stockpile
with the cova 19 outbreak we now have a
similar situation but at a greater scale
the major difference now is that our
team does not have to respond in
isolation
our bioxp instrument and the tools we
created are now available to the rest of
the world
and has enabled a distributed
manufacturing response where scientists
can now work collaboratively
and in parallel as a community to get
ahead of the coronavirus
outbreak and generate a vaccine against
it
with increased international travel on a
population expected to reach 10 billion
people
by the year 2050 we are going to need
innovative synthetic biology solutions
for vaccines diagnostics and treatments
for this pandemic and future disease
outbreaks
our automated dna printing solutions
have great potential in rapidly creating
vaccines on the front lines and for
specifically
tailoring the vaccine to match the
strain circulating in a particular area
and this approach can be used for all
vaccine types whether it's dna vaccines
rna vaccines viral vector vaccines
protein based
vaccines or even live attenuated
vaccines
next you will hear from katie lyons who
is the senior scientist at codex
uh katie has been a part of our
organization from day one
and worked with the engineers to get the
bio biology running
on the bio xp instrument uh she will
discuss
the bio xp and escape abilities then you
will hear from
krishna cannon who is a staff scientist
at codex
krishna has been on my team for several
years and has played important roles in
several synthetic cell projects
he will discuss how he used the bioxp to
rapidly construct
the complete star's kobe 2 genome
uh thanks a lot dan so my name is katie
lyons and
i'm a senior scientist at codex
and i'm really actually very excited to
be talking with everyone
today this pandemic has been
such a challenge on so many levels but
in the scientific community
it's been really energizing and really
exciting to
collaborate with so many people and have
the chance to share our technology
um so dan gave a really nice
overview of the tool that i'm going to
be talking today and i think of it
kind of as a leg up that we have um
in accelerating research and it's
something near and dear to my heart
since i've been working on it for a
really long time and working with it for
a long time
um but i think the real key here is
the work that dan talked about and
the work that krishna has done um all of
this
can be done without the tool
the bio xp which i'm going to be talking
about um
but in order when when there's pressure
on for example like yeah one
pretty much every day every uh second
almost matters
um so it's important to use every tool
that you have at your disposal
in order to accelerate your workflow and
do everything as quickly and efficiently
and as correctly as possible um
so sort of the crux of where we use this
machine and the reason that it helps us
to move so quickly
in a time like this is it reduces
friction that can happen at so many
points along the way
uh when you're building genes or
building genomes
um the driver in creating this tool was
to make it completely hands-free
and to allow both seasoned synthetic
biologists who do this
by hand all the time and also people who
don't
to have the same exact experience which
is extremely easy
of loading the machine pressing start
and letting it do its thing
and out when the program completes you
have your built genes
um over time we've
increased the range of the machine so
when this idea was first
sent my way being a person who builds
these things normally
you just think it's not possible like
how can you have one
protocol to build all of these different
types of sequences
um and be able to without
any uh input you know of checking
something on the gel
or making sure something worked you know
we sort of completely blindly synthesize
something from start to back
um but so so when we started off this
machine was
you know what we could do in those types
of
parameters but over time you know we've
just gotten better and better and what
was initially a narrow range of
um constructs is now incredibly broad
um we have expanded our complexity
um and our size and our
versatility also in ways that we can
approach these builds and i'll tell you
more about that um
additionally everything is controlled
again so if you're working with a
multi-channel pipettor
you sometimes don't notice that one of
the channels didn't aspirate or whatever
um in this case we know if that channel
didn't aspirate
um and everything is done
exactly uh in a controlled environment
in the same way
every time so you can basically trust
the results that come off the machine
um we've also expanded um the
versatility
and um we had initially again
offered sort of a very simple
you know fragment type of build on these
machines
um but now we've expanded that to
include cloning
and um a second uh amplification step to
allow you to go up to microgram
on a piece of dna um i'll tell you all
about that
um in a few slides and
um one of the big things also is that
this machine is very supported
so you can be involved as much or as
little
as you like and how much you know about
this machine and how much you interface
with this machine
um if you know a ton about design and
you have
excellent prediction tools and um you're
kind of a seasoned
person and enjoy doing it like i do
you may want to just pass something like
a sequence to our team
and um a new pda type sequence and
you know that's it it goes into the
portal it gets
sent back to you and you run it on the
machine
but um if you don't really want to be
involved at all
send us we have an excellent customer
service department
and that's your protein sequence we can
help you here design it
we can put on optimization um we can
help you avoid complexity
there's a whole lot of information that
is held in the heads of the people that
work here
um and then i think the last one is a
little bit tongue-in-cheek but i wanted
to say
uh this machine is catched by the
lineage
in that um it was it's the product
of um the work of people like dan
um people who do
this type of assembly day in and day out
and do the hardest types of assemblies
um we have no one for magicians who have
contributed enormously
to um allowing us to make these
sequences
uh synthesizable by this
or automatically um we have
engineers who are top-notch and work
with our biologists
um if you want a robot
to make your dna this is i guess
actually it's the only one so um
anyway this is what we do this is this
is
responsible pandemics is where we what
we're building
so it's really exciting actually to be
able to
so i'll just kind of tell you a little
bit more about the machine in more
detail
so this is what you'll observe
outside of
so you order a sequence and that like i
said can be
protein or nucleotide um
we are able to help you with codon
optimization we have a full database
and um whether or not we
this machine will have issues
synthesizing that
sequence and not only that but we can
design around it
um from there you get this uh
nice looking kit which is a schematic
i'm sure among the right and so you'll
receive a kit that
arrives with everything you need to make
that and and that's shown in the
schematics
um then you take those materials you
load them following a map um to onto the
bioxp
and then close the door hit start um
most of our protocols take uh
somewhere between 12 uh actually even
shorter than that it can be
something like eight to about uh 24
hours
for the the very longest amplification
that we have
but generally this is something like an
overnight run you started in the
afternoon and then the next morning
it's done for you so next morning you
work with your jeans or clones or
amplifications whatever
kit you've decided to order and you're
ready to go to the next morning
so all said um that's about four to six
days and the capacity of the machine is
32 genes per run
okay so now a little bit um where the
nuts and bolts of what goes on
inside the machine um if you're
interested
um so basically we have
taken our we we patented this
oligonucleotide
nucleotide assembly method um
years ago and it had it's it's really
the chassis that everything works off of
um like i said the starting blocks the
building materials are
um oligonucleotides um these are then
assembled into
a double-stranded fragment um
but because these are again made from
synthetic oligos
they are error-prone they're they're
just randomly
sprinkled with errors throughout that
fragment so even though it's built
beautifully
um it's pretty much not usable at this
stage
the next step then is to on the
part of the part of the workflow of the
machine
is to start the error correction
protocol
and that is based on again i i was kind
of tooting the horn of
of our air correction enzyme so it's a
it's a mismatch
recognition nuclease and it's it's
scanning across four
bubbles in the dna where there's an
imperfect um
heteroduplex so that that's
cut and repaired and um
then there's actually i i didn't show
this on the slide but there's a second
buildback step uh you you end up after
after the oligo
sorry after the air correction um you
end up basically with a big
um shear profile of of dna
where all of these um heteroduplexes
have been cut at various spots
so there's a buildback step and then
after that
you do have nice material that is error
free and
nicely built back in double-stranded
format
so the next step and this is just
perfectly amenable for
automation is the base cleanup um so we
have a magnet on the deck and
like perfect uh robot liquid handling so
um when we were developing this machine
this was the
in the early days you know a human was
pretty much better at every single part
of this
except the purification with which you
just can't beat a robot for doing that
um and then so the last panel there is
an example of the gel
of um this is 32 jeans they're very
similar um
in their sequence and you just get this
super nice gel and you have 32
third or two jeans ready to go um i
will say that this is not always how
perfect they look
but in general we have very robust
buildback and uh this is not unusual to
see
see such a pretty gel like this
so now i'm going to shift gears a little
bit and talk about
more of the applications of the bioxp
we focused on the last slide about the
kind of the foundation of the
the workflow of the biox key which is
building fragments and i just added a
little bit of information in terms of
how big these fragments can be i talked
earlier about the complexity so there's
a certain
uh threshold and certain
parameters that we look for there but
the other one which is very simple
is just um we prefer that the fragments
are between 300 base pairs and 1.8 kb
that's the sweet spot um on this machine
running a fragment style of
um program
um so you can imagine in
the cyrus cov2 landscape
someone like krishna and he'll tell us
about this later
putting together all of these fragments
to build the genome
so they can be component fragments or
they can be standalone
but this is the very foundation of the
way this machine runs
but there's more which is uh sort of a
value added
and another way to look at this is
perhaps most importantly
um another sort of bell and whistle
attached to this
is to increase the hands-free time from
gene building and stopping there where
the the
human gets involved to work on
downstream processing
but you can extend that one more step by
having the machine
clone the fragment directly into
your vector of choice and end up with a
circular
circular plasmid that's gone through
gibson assembly and
contains the synthetic dna that you just
built
additionally this can be multiplexed so
that the
synthetic portion can be increased from
one fragment to four fragments and
effectively
increase that synthetic build size from
1.8 kb maximum to something more like
7kb
uh additionally conserved sequences can
be added between
that would be added by the user along
with the vector
and just increases the versatility of
the way that you can use this and
maybe more creatively construct what you
need to make
and then i also wanted to touch on um
another another way that you can build
dna fragments they don't have to be one
specific sequence they can be they can
be libraries
in this depiction we're showing a
scanning nnn library site saturation of
a specific
area of a gene you can imagine
interrogating something like an
active site and um the way that this
that the bioxp builds these we're able
to
use the repeated sequences
in all of the libraries so what this
does
is very effectively cuts down on the
time it takes to make these libraries
this is the product that runs with the
shortest amount of time
roughly eight hours to complete one of
these runs
and additionally because we're able to
reuse so many of those components
as if they're repeated in all of those
sequences it really effectively costs
cuts the cost as well
and then finally back to the circular
style of building
um we have a method called rapidamp
it's a standalone reagent that's
available but also can be
added to the bioxp workflow um
this capitalizes on a circular template
so again this would be something like a
clone that's gone through
uh circularization via gibson assembly
can be done on the machine
and this is just one additional step to
the hands-free pipeline
that scales up this very small number of
molecules in the nanogram
quantity that are circular and cloned
containing whatever number of synthetic
dna fragments you've decided to add
and scales this number up from nanogram
quantities to
about 10 micrograms of final dna
so what that does effectively is
remove the in vivo component of
the scale up so there's no
overnight culture there's no
purification
this is dna that's generated
cell free and microgram quantities
which can then be used directly in
transfections or transcriptions as
templates
one thing that doesn't need to be done
the dna that comes off of
the machine the the first step that the
user would do is to
digest it down into monomers which is
what this picture is showing
and from there you're ready to go so
it's a significant time
savings and um also another component
that adds
about six hours onto the run time but
saves you the overnight seal up and the
purification
that needs to happen in vivo
so with that i just want to
pass it over to krishna i hope that now
everyone has lots of great ideas on
uh fast and effective ways to combat the
virus and
krishna will tell us all about how he
generated the first fully synthetic
starship genome
thanks kelly i'm gonna start with a
brief primer
on the process of hierarchical assembly
this was developed by a team of
scientists at jcdi
led by dan gibson what i'm showing here
are two prominent examples that
demonstrate
how hierarchical assembly has been
successfully deployed
to build synthetic genomes completely
denoble from oligonucleotides
the microplasma gel italian genome
that's a little above
half a million base pairs and the
microplatform microarray is genome which
is about 1 million base pairs
were built using this process
hierarchical assembly
in its liberal sense refers to the
technology
to enable building genomes or large
complex dna
in stages of increasing complexity
the process of hierarchical assembly
entails breaking the genome
down to small overlapping pieces
sometimes up to three orders of
magnitude compared to the size of the
colon genome this
essentially lends itself to the
synthesis process
from oligonucleotides we refer to these
as stage 1 molecules
small pieces of genome could then be
cloned into vectors in sequence
certified
before moving on to the next stage of
assembly
the statement molecules will then be
stitched together to create
stage 2 molecules and stage 2 molecules
will be assembled into
larger stage 3 molecules so on and so
forth
this way at each subsequent step of the
assembly process
we increase the complexity of the dna
that's been constructed
specifically in terms of length for
example
these stage two molecules could be two
to ten times
larger compared to these stage one
molecules this process
is repeated until we assemble the entire
genome
as a single construct several
technologies
had to be developed in order to
successfully deploy the hierarchical
assembly process
to build genomes as one can imagine
we need a really good design of software
to be able to design the entire assembly
process
in stages to enable hierarchical
assembly
the gibbs an assembly method to switch
dna
molecules with homologous ends is
another wonderful outcome
of the genome synthesis project the
flexibility to shuttle between bacterial
and
east host organisms and the development
of transmission assisted recombination
cloning method
in east were also important to enable
the synthesis of large and complex dna
molecules
including genomes
now i'll provide an overview of how we
used
the hierarchical assembly process to
synthesize this
source for visual genome
we used our proprietary software to
break the genome
down to 24 overlapping 1.4 kb
parts in silicon
again these would constitute the stage 1
molecules
3 consecutive stage 1 molecules were
then combined using gibson assembly
to generate stage 2 molecules each
approximately 5 kb left 6 of these stage
2 molecules were then combined again
using gives an assembly to generate
stage three molecule
which ended up being the final stage of
the hierarchical assembly process
resulting in that roughly 30 kb genome
of sarsko v2
the stage one molecules were generated
using the bioxp
3200 system like i mentioned earlier
these one molecules consist of 24
overlapping dna constructs
that are about 1.4 kb inlet
these molecules were designed in order
through the bioxy portal
and once the reagents were available
we executed this resulted
in the generation of error corrective
and amplified
24 stage 1 molecules that span the
entire genome
of sarsko v2 in a single overnight one
we then cloned these stable molecules
and obtained sequence accurate loans
which were then used in subsequent
stages of the hierarchical assembly
we combined three consecutive signal
molecules through gibson assembly method
in order to generate six stage two
molecules
these molecules were then combined again
to the final the into the final phase of
the hierarchical assembly
is stage three in this case using gibson
assembly method
in order to generate the phone genome
the genome was captured in the bacterial
artificial chromosome at this
final stage of assembly we verified the
presence of woodland's genome in our
clones using several methods
since the genome that we cloned was
fairly large
we used to be called field inversion
cell electrophoresis
or physique in short to be able to
resolve the clone dna
at higher solution we used
restriction enzyme digestion of the dna
isolated from our clones to release the
sars covetous genome
and analyzed this dna using widget
this enabled us to easily visualize the
cloned high molecular weight dna
we also subjected the source covated
genome cloned
in the back to the supercoil dna
analysis
which clearly indicated the size of the
dna deposit
this process involved resolving
undigested
coolant dna alongside site standards
to estimate the size of the dna that was
grown
we then picked a few clones and
identified a sequence accurate clone
using next generation sequencing
freedom coverage across one such clone
is shown on the slide
this concludes how we generated the
fullen genome
and i will now move on to the
applications of the full-length
genome synthesis technology
live attenuator vaccines are one of the
most important applications
of equivalent genome synthesis
technology
there are several advantages of live
autonomous vaccines including
low pass the durable engine response
boosters are rarely needed it involves
low cost
and also generates really fast premium
response
attenuated vaccines have been extremely
successful
for all presidential reasons
to provide immunity against viral
diseases
such as nasals mums rubella
smallpox chickenpox folio yellow fever
and also against bacterial diseases such
as typhoid and tuberculosis
they live attenuated vaccines technology
already exists
for influenza or seasonal flu
one can imagine that a similar
technology would be developed for source
code v2
as well there are several genetic
changes that can be quickly generated
within the source cov2 genome for
example inactivation of specific
proteins would render the
wireless replication definitions are
unable to correct the errors that occur
during replication
these changes can then be successfully
used to generate live attenuated
versions
of the sars4 v2 virus which can be used
as a vaccine the importance
of the development of diagnostics for
soft skill we do cannot be overstated
at this point with different genome we
can assist the development of
rna or dna based diagnostics that span
the entirety
of the genome these could be rdpcr
or next generation sequencing data
assays
this is important because it enables
researchers to pick
any number of targets from any or all
parts of the genome
and successfully develop diagnostics
not only that our technology also allows
for the rapid generation of
diagnostic against specific genomic
variants
of source coverage as well some of the
other applications of whole genome
synthesis technology are highlighted on
the slide
we discussed one aspect of vaccine
development
against covid19 but of course there are
multiple ways to train the immune system
against the substance
all of these methods can be fully
supported by the whole genome synthesis
technology
using full-length genomes researchers
are also able to choose from
any number of antigens within these
genome to target for the development of
therapeutics as well
such as antibodies another important
application
would be using the moderate versions of
the human genome of sunscreen v2
to study the virus itself for example
tagging different arts with reporter
proteins can help us understand the life
cycle of the virus during
entry and infection
this concludes my section of the talk i
thank everybody for their attention
with this i'm gonna throw it back here
all right thanks very much krishna so
while everyone is submitting their
questions i would like to highlight that
in addition to the bioxp 3200 system
we actually have a number of products
and services that we've recently
developed including the cyrus co2
full-length synthetic genome that
krishna was just referencing
the full-length genome is actually
available with or without a t7 promoter
region
and additionally we have rna controls
with overlapping fragments available for
diagnostic assay development
okay and with that i would like to go
ahead and open up the floor for our q a
session with krishna
thank you dr gibson dr cannon and dr
lyons for your informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of our webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen
and now let's get started okay our first
question is
what role do you see codex playing once
the immediate threat of covet 19 is
passed
so um my name is krishna cannon i'm
happy to answer the questions
um so one thing that
uh codex has been focused on is
developing
rapid dna writing technologies
and it's not just about synthesizing dna
molecules
really quickly but we also make really
accurate dna molecules as well
so one role that codex can play
once the coordinating dynamics is behind
us
we can essentially enable the research
community and scientists around the
world
to be able to be better prepared for
pandemics like these
we are enabling distributed
manufacturing in terms of
dna writing technologies and we are
going to come up with a whole suite of
products as well
which is going to help the scientific
community
in a lot of ways to be better prepared
for future pandemic
thank you and dr cannon what are some of
your other
covid offerings
so um
codex has several official products
you just heard how we synthesize the
volume genome
we have those genomes available off the
shelf
for researchers around the world uh to
enable them to develop vaccines
uh diagnostics and therapeutics um
we also are very open to collaborating
with people
um around the world to generate custom
genomes so not just the wild type genome
that's available of the shop
we can make designer genomes for you if
you're interested in uh
trying out different designs to develop
for example
levitt invaded vaccines we have
come out with rna controls that are both
overlapping
and non-overlapping so this way you get
100
coverage of the source code genome
um and we also have library services
that are available
for use and just come and talk to us so
visit us
at codexdna.com we have several products
and services that are ready
available for customers
now dr cannon i'd like to hear your
opinion on this
as a leader in the field do you think
the synthetic biology community has
responded
adequately to the ongoing pandemic
um i think we have done the best we can
with the
tools that are available but what's
really going to make a difference is
um new tools that
would be developed which will enable
researchers to write dna faster
and get to their final designs much
faster
and that's what's that's what codex is
trying to enable
people around the world it's distributed
manufacturing of dna writing
that we want everybody to be able to use
um and generate their dna without dna
you're not able to do a lot of things
especially if you're in this field of
trying to combat a pandemic
like covet 19 so hopefully once
we have uh distributed manufacturing in
biology i mean the speaker plans
actually does exist for other fields but
not in biology
really um codex is trying to make that
happen
so that's what's going to make a
difference
when we encounter a future pandemic
what do you think we could have done
better to increase our general
preparedness
for future pandemics
so this goes along the lines of the
answer
that i just gave it's it's all about
how distributed manufacturing can work
in biology so instead of having
centralized
manufacturing for your starting material
which is
most likely the dna that you use for
research purposes
and you know if you want to develop
vaccines or therapeutics or diagnostics
you're going to start with a dna
and just to the power of enabling
this capability for researchers around
the world
it's it's going to be extremely
important and useful
and it's going to make us much better
prepared for future family
thank you dr cannon and we have some
great questions coming in and we have
time for a few more but i do want to
remind our audience that
any questions we're unable to answer
today and those
additionally that are submitted during
the on-demand period
they will be addressed by our speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
okay let's continue what is the
turnaround time
for submitting a sequence to final
output
so there are um two ways of answering
this you're able to
um we just brought our service option
back so you're able to order sequences
off of our website and we can synthesize
these sequences for you and the
turnaround time
generally depends on how complex and how
big the sequence is
but if you are talking about the 5xp if
you have access to a bioxp
or dna printer then
once you input the sequence on our bio
xp
portal within three three to four days
you receive a reason block from us and
after an
overnight run a single overnight run can
actually
produce 32 different 1.8 kb gene
fragments for you
so within a week you'll have access to
this dna
excellent thank you what other
applications can this technology support
beyond vaccine development
there are several applications of
dna synthesis in general and i'll speak
to
the whole genome synthesis technology um
just to be able to make modifications
in the genome of a virus like this which
is
very novel and to be able to study the
virus
and we've had several people approaches
to me approaches for making
modifications in the genome
which include okay can we have reported
genes in the genome or can we make
can we tag different genes in the genome
and all this is going to help people is
to
study the virus itself because it is a
new virus and we are trying to
understand how it works
that's going to be an important
application as well apart from the live
attenuator vaccines or
in general other vaccines to dna rna
vaccines
or viral vector vaccines and other
diagnostics or therapeutics that people
can develop using the whole genome
technology
dr cannon can we order sars kovi to full
length synthetic genome itself from
codex
or do we need the bioxp system to
synthesize
our own synthetic you can do both
um the sasko v2 filling genome is
available
from codex dna it's an off the shelf
product that's available for our
customers
we do a very careful screening of our
customers of course
to make sure that it doesn't end up in
the wrong hands
or you could get a buy xp from us and
you're able to synthesize
parts of the genome and put it together
as well
thank you dr cannon and we have time for
one more question
let's let's go with this one how many
back clones do you need to sequence to
get a stars cov2 sequence without
any errors wow
like kb described we do have a
proprietary error correction process
which enables the bioxp to generate
really
really
accurate dna molecules so we didn't have
to uh
sequence a lot of back loans to
get to an accurate one we did sequence
24 but we found a lot of positives in
that
so it it wasn't a lot
thank you dr cannon and do you have any
final comments for our audience
uh just one thing visit us at
codexdna.com we have a lot of
products that are off the shelf or that
are
custom solutions that might be available
for you
if especially if you are in covid19
research we just want to help people
around the world to get through this
pandemic
and we are putting our technology to
full use
to enable uh researchers around the
world to develop tools
uh to combat the pandemic so visit us
visit us at codextma.com
you dr cannon and to our audience you
can also visit codex dna right now
in our corona virus event i would like
to once again
thank dr cannon dr gibson and dr lyons
for their informative presentation and
dr cannon for this excellent q a
i'd also like to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
as a reminder those questions we were
unable to answer today
and those that are submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speakers via the contact information
you provided
at the time of registration one final
thank you to our sponsor codex dna for
sponsoring today's webinar
this webcast can be viewed on demand
through the end of this year
2020 labyrinths will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now we
hope to see you again
soon have a great day